Bladerunner 2049 seemed like a surefire
hit with two hollywood favorites sharing
the lead tons of critical praise and a
respectable box-office forecast however
the long awaited sequel brought in just
31 point five million dollars an opening
weekend which is a pretty dismal return
compared to its 150 million dollar
production budget so why did this film
fizzle out in the theaters let's take a
look at what went wrong with Blade
Runner 2049 runtime Blade Runner 2049
comes in at a whopping 163 minutes which
seems to have been just long enough to
dissuade casual viewers from a trip to
the theater while sci-fi fans might
still be willing to spend that much time
with the movie those just looking for a
fun time would probably be more in the
mood for something a bit on the shorter
side not only that but the number of
showings each theater can host per day
is significantly lessened by its length
which can lead to a loss of revenue
overall when it comes to movies longer
isn't always better
sequel slow Hollywood's all about
reboots and sequels but usually the
underlying property is something that
was successful the first time around
while 1982's Blade Runner has since
amassed an intense cult following it's
easy to forget that it didn't actually
perform very well during its brief
theatrical run overshadowed by et the
extra-terrestrial the film stayed in
theaters for just five weeks and earned
only thirty two point nine million
dollars which is about 82 million
dollars if you adjust for inflation and
not only was the first film only mildly
popular upon release but there's since
been several different cuts released on
video and DVD like the Final Cut
released in 2007 all those cuts are
confusing to casual fans and meant those
potential moviegoers for 2049 had to
decide between watching one of at least
three different versions of the original
before heading out to the theater that's
a whole lot of homework especially for a
weekend bloated budget given the
lackluster initial interest in the
original it was a risky move for Warner
Brothers to invest so much capital in
the sequel twenty-five years later
1982's Blade Runner was made on a big
budget for its time costing a reported
thirty million dollars to make which
translates to about 76 million dollars
today but Blade Runner 2049 is estimated
to have cost twice that amount after tax
rebates it might have allowed for
gorgeous visuals at all but it was also
a risky investment for a movie that was
25 years overdue and leaning on a
property the
wasn't a financial runaway to begin with
vague marketing one common thread among
recent box-office flops is marketing
that focuses on visuals over substance
thanks to big bombs like valerian in the
city of a thousand planets and ghost in
the shell' audiences have grown weary of
bad films being disguised with sweeping
camera shots in a big budget well this
didn't end up being the case with Blade
Runner 2049 the trailers might not have
drummed as much buzz as they could have
thanks to how they highlight the movies
looks over its plots of course the
entire plot of the movie itself was a
spoiler but keeping details under wraps
did them no favors in terms of bringing
in viewers unfamiliar with the source
material too many questions too faithful
there's a lot of complicated mythology
at play in the Blade Runner films many
fans and critics were delightfully
surprised to see how well the sequel
dealt with it with the film answering
and expanding and some of the deeper
questions asked in the original however
that type of introspection and that deep
connection to the mythology makes it
daunting for the unconverted the mythos
of Blade Runner is so deep and
complicated that it can keep casual
viewers at arm's length in 20 49 may
have stucked too close to the source
material to have the kind of mass appeal
it was aiming for intense competition
Blade Runner 2049 had trouble attracting
young audiences and that may be in part
thanks to its art rating after years of
shying away from adult oriented fare
studios have been more willing to
embrace it lately in fact it seems like
those films have started flooding the
marketplace but 2049 had to stand up
against r-rated competition like the
still popular it American assassin and
Kingsman the Golden Circle all of which
were much easier to digest than Blade
Runner going for a less strict rating
would have helped to cut out some of the
competition and likely wouldn't have
seriously cut into the film's quality
considering the movie is fairly tame for
its our rating what now Blade Runner
2049 like many a domestic flop now turns
to the international box office for
salvation the movie brought in fifty
point two million dollars overseas
during its debut just about on par with
expectations although not enough to make
up for its domestic failure the movies
biggest hope lies in Asian market
releases which come later in October and
November nations like South Korea and
China are more friendly to movies with
big-budget visuals so if the film was
able to bring in big bucks overseas it
could still be profitable and while
Hollywood is a business even
the film's receipts aren't as strong as
the studio might have hoped the movie
definitely has cult favorite potential
just like its predecessor so who knows
we might just be seeing a third Blade
Runner installment drop in another 25
years thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]